it was meant to be the thrill of a
lifetime a submarine trip to the site of
one of the most famous Maritime wrecks
the RMS Titanic but this journey has
turned into a rescue operation of its
own the submersible reported overdue for
a check-in on Sunday with one pilot and
four others on board we're working very
closely at this point to make sure that
we're doing everything that we can do to
locate the submersible and rescue those
on board the submarine called the Titan
is missing nearly 1500 kilometers off
the Boston Coast where the ocean bottom
can be four thousand meters down contact
was lost one hour and 45 minutes after
it submerged now planes with radar are
searching for any sight of it on the
surface while sooner is being used by
vessels to see if there's anything
subsea extra resources are speeding to
the area we are deploying all available
assets to make sure that uh we can
locate the craft and
rescue the people on board the Titanic
sank in 1912 and it's maiden voyage from
the UK to America more than 1500 people
died the vessel's story has become
iconic featuring in several books
documentaries and movies the company
which operates the submersible sends out
several trips around this time of year
British businessman himacharding was one
of those on board posting on Instagram
as he was about to set off on a trip
which costs a quarter of a million
dollars for seven nights the submersible
has 96 hours of air it can draw on in an
emergency deep submersible diving is
very dangerous but it is it's high tech
you know and it's each year goes by the
equipment gets better the technology
gets better and so on so I'm very
hopeful and very positive I I mean I was
in the sub for 12 hours we have our own
breathing system on board and if that's
maintained properly like changing your
filter and your CO2 scrubber you can
stay down there for you know quite a few
hours the extra resources will start
arriving on scene in the coming hours
but it is a massive area to cover and
what is clear is that this is now very
much a Race Against Time Alan Fisher Al
Jazeera